- You grew up in a suburb
on the south side of Chicago.
How do you think that affected you
during this time?
- I grew up in a suburb
and there is all the difference.
And had I grown up in
the south side of Chicago
where both of my parents
worked, the actual city
my experience would have
been a lot different.
But as I was in a suburb,
it was a new suburb,
it was the Manifest Destiny of people
who lived in Chicago to go south
and to create these suburbs
and we were the original settlers
(laughing)
of Dolton, Illinois in 1960.
And we were, I wasn't even
aware of the Vietnam War
and I was 10 in 1970, so
you think I would have.
I kind of vaguely heard about it.
My parents didn't talk about
it at the dinner table.
I wasn't aware of anything going on.
And it wasn't until I moved
out here to Los Angeles,
I live in Laurel Canyon,
and I became familiar
with what went on here
like musically and politically
and the time I was growing up
and I had no idea.
So, I was in kind of a bubble.
And I think being gay
you kind of, you have to
get out of your comfort.
I think that that just demands
that you step away from where it's safe
because you can't fully express yourself
if you stay there.
So, I was, after college
I went to the city
and learned a lot more.
And what compelled me to move to the city
was the fact that I
probably couldn't be gay
in Dolton, Illinois, open.
But I could be in the city.
So, I just dove right into
it and I learned a lot.
- I mean, that's a whole other thing, too.
Just, and you mentioned
in Marvelous Mrs. Maisel
even being a woman that
can be very difficult.
Being gay can be difficult.
It's all those, it's
like if you think of...
I think sometimes people aren't impacted
unless it directly impacts you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So you just
have to rephrase it.
Being gay in a place that
that's not generally acceptable
or people are fearful of
it or just don't know it
that's a whole, that's
the same kind of thing
in a sense of not feeling
safe to be yourself
not feeling safe outside of your home.
You had to move to a different place.
That's ridiculous.
Like, all of that is insane to me.
- Yeah.
- And I just thank you
'cause I actually do see
you on Twitter quite a bit.